thank you
[Music]
all right so uh there's this uh this
incident that happened right uh World
Cup winner Jenny hermoso from Spain uh
was after she had gotten the metal put
on her uh when Spain had beat England
1-0 the uh she received the medal from
the FIFA president Gianni Infantino and
then afterwards she starts chatting with
uh I believe the Spanish fa boss Luis
rubiales and then in a spontaneous
moment that was caught in media and
stuff like that of Happiness apparently
he just kisses her like grabs her face
and like kisses her on the lips on the
lips I saw what I saw when I saw her
trying to make out with the guy
wait so guy kisses girl on the lips or
girl kisses guy on the lips well it's
it's spun into kind of like a lot of
different things including including
first him going on to social media and
being like it was a we have a great
relationship it was a spontaneous moment
but I do realize that that probably
shouldn't have happened did she come out
saying that was inappropriate I didn't
know that it was non-consensual oh and
then it goes into another moment where
the Spanish fa accuses her of lying
about the kiss of the president so like
you know kind of like try to get dicey
wait are they Spanish yeah I feel like
they [__] make out all over the town
is that a cultural thing
I thought it was dude when I saw like
like Italians and everybody kiss each
other they're saying I was like that's
family what the [__] are you doing you
like sucking each other's toes saying hi
bye jeez that's the culture right the
guys kiss each other no yeah no guys
suck each other's earlobes yeah that
thing yeah yeah they're not gay dude
they don't kiss each other's lips they
suck each other's ears they go kisses
they go that's very Euro yeah but now
now we're at a part where in the story
where the World Cup winner Jenny Hermosa
has now filed a complaint over the
unsolicited kiss uh so now that's kind
of where this is and if we'll just watch
the video real quick of like when and
how fast it happened just so yeah we
should all have contacts
I don't know I think you're like heck
he's holding her face pretty yeah
let's see this again
oh
that looks crazy to us but we're [__]
all the way over here I think that's all
that in reverse that doesn't look that
doesn't look like Mal intent it looks
like just out of the Heat of the Moment
yeah to me totally which is what he also
yeah is that the coach or who was he uh
he's like the fa president uh because if
he's like an announcer it's like what
the [__] are you doing Larry Nasser Bud
yeah but it's like it's I guess if you
don't want it it's kind of both though
you know what I mean because that
reminds me like credit card in the chips
as we're going by credit card yeah
because it's not like a Joe Biden sniff
no yeah that's quicker hit that screen
hold on grab that chick's titty no what
the heck yeah I'll show you guys
tomorrow I'll see you today
[Laughter]
I guess it just all comes down to if she
wanted to do that or not and if she
didn't then yeah that's it I think I I
don't know enough about like
certain European cultures and what their
levels of but if she says it wasn't cool
then obviously he broke some type of
rule right definitely yeah he apologized
and he said quote we are facing a
historic event one of the happiest days
in Spanish football we are world
champion something for which we have
been working hard and for which we feel
proud but there's also a fact that I
have to regret and that is all that uh
what happened between me and a player
with whom there is a magnificent
relationship and where I was surely
wrong in a moment of Maximum now that's
an apology that's a good apology so far
without any bad intentions and no bad
faith had happened in a very spontaneous
way here we did not understand the
controversy and there has been a
commotion outside that if there are
people who have felt damage because of
this I have to apologize and learn from
this there's no other option dude that's
like the anthropology it's like if Genie
bus kissed Kobe Bryant on the mouth well
like that right that's like kind of the
same that's like when if Joe Rogan
kissed Conor McGregor in the mouth
that's like that that's like that it's
my dream that's my dream no because that
reminds me of uh so my dad vowed to take
uh never show his son affection
yeah
and then and I remember driving it was
during the the period where like I was
getting my acceptance letters or
rejection letters from college yeah and
then I remember picking it from the
mailbox and he was driving and I'm just
like opening them one by one and I
remember opening one on my oh they
accepted me and my dad I think he just
accidentally broke his vow and he went
boom we saw him good job he went back to
like this that's what it looked like
like it just looked like he had just a
huge thing of emotion you're so proud
I'm so proud of you and then
you know yeah that was his kiss that was
a [__] punch tonight you're lucky it
wasn't your face it was a beautiful
moment I'm a little weakness for him
that's kind of cool good you see him as
weak after that you're like you're weak
you affectionate [__] I can't hurt a
little bit I should have followed the
complain dude
so we think this guy's innocent right we
all think I think so just from his
behavior no I can't have Hive mentality
obviously I agree with that yeah yeah
yeah if it was the other way around like
if a girl kissed a guy and the guy
complained wouldn't everyone just look
at the guys like you [__] [__]
that's the double standard part that's
nice well she's hot she's hot if she's
hot yeah yeah but no one would complain
if the guy was gay
that's true he'll be like that Predator
[__] she knows he's gay if that was
Ryan Seacrest yeah that'd be a lot
different
and everyone would come to protect him
because they're like he likes men not
your ugly ass woman lips exactly but
what if she's hot but if she was hot it
still doesn't make them straight dude
it's that [__] up thing where we see
like you know some 15 year old kids
[__] a teacher and she's hot and
we're like yup hey it's a real it
honestly is a real thing give him a
medal but not if it was a hop man that's
in his 40s looking like a model and then
uh a teen girl that is kind of like a
wrong porno yeah yeah that's weird you
don't like that yeah yeah keep it to
Pornhub yeah but if it's like
because maybe a little bit more
scenarios because maybe a little bit of
our 14 year old selves are just like oh
you're so lucky dude my teachers were so
hot I had so many hot teachers I was
growing up in San Diego dude there's a
lot of yeah did they teach in bikinis
yeah they might as well have this dude
v-neck era right yeah and I had a
teacher with the massive titties like
massive mommy [__] milkers and they
know what they're doing when they
[__] put those they do and her her
waist was like [__] this small by the
way it was insane what a concept it just
spawns it made no sense
it was like dexterity did you just I'm
telling you bro it didn't make any
[__] sense it was like that's awesome
people are like they're like yelling at
comic book jars and stuff being like you
guys gonna represent real women I'm like
I saw a real woman in my math class bro
yeah trust me
my second grade teacher looked like a
Red Hot Chili Peppers groupie and she
gave all the kids hugs and we just loved
it because her titties were so nice
those are the best hugs I ever got in my
life but I didn't know what sex was at
second grade but I just knew that
something about this teacher was way
better than the grandma one yeah
anytime she opened her mouth you'd be
like yeah I agree yeah this you're right
this is interesting
it seems like this is like a he even if
this wasn't innocent action he's already
at a level in a position where he just
can't be doing [__] like that honestly
yeah like if you're that high up like
haven't you been primered already that
like hey things can get pretty bad if
you do the wrong thing yeah it's I guess
it's cool until the other person doesn't
feel comfortable with that but you also
said Spain's been [__] sucking right
and sucking and losing and losing and
sucking I finally won so they're like so
happy they're like yes and so I think
out of like uh just like a moment of
like I didn't kind of slap a plan in the
ass no [__] why did I do that I think at
the end of the day a televised
non-consensual kiss regardless of the
circumstance it's gonna get some heat
you'll get here yeah yeah it's it's just
asking for him I think he should have
been like you guys should see me kiss my
[__] mom and then you should post a
video of him oh yeah yeah I've been like
saying hi this is how we say hi in my
culture that's what he should have done
like after he does it if he knew that he
did something wrong he should have
turned to the next guy
and it's not about her
anymore for 30 counts
the whole team and his mom and his mom
mom was actually super pissed about this
too she like wrote like an open thing
like what did she say she was saying
that like everyone was like trapping him
or something it wasn't fair or something
he was coming to his defense right yeah
she came to his defense it was like [__]
all you guys he's uh so we eat the boy
sure it's like it probably wasn't like a
sexual thing but then it's cultural
context if you saw this [__] in Germany
you're like clearly those [__] cold
unromantic [__] should not be
doing this this is really out of context
right but when it's Italian Spanish
Brazilian I'm just like I don't know
yeah that's what I'm saying because
because we're a man of the men of the
world yeah we just know that it's
different in different societies because
if they did this [__] and [__] they
do this in Greece yeah oh it's okay it's
all good don't do this [__] drink
wine together and suck each other off
during a celebration is it a Mykonos
yeah it's all good everything Greece is
probably gonna be wearing underwear yeah
China no for China you go to jail no no
no you don't kiss in China you can't
even make official in the government
then you can do whatever you want then
you can do it at least he wasn't trying
to defend it like to the death or
something yeah I [__] up I shouldn't
have done that I like that apology it's
good apology he's like your boy was a
little sneaky a little sneaky back there
that's what that's what they should have
said for the Dalai Lama instead of just
trying to bring up all the [__] oh
[__] that was crazy yeah this was like
suck my tongue it's like no one cares
that's literally what you do it's like
you're at a world standard bro like you
can't just be you can't be asking people
to suck your tongue I don't care what
your [__] culture is kids sucking on
your tongue should probably rooted out
of it if I asked my wife to suck on my
tongue and it was a perfectly like
romantic that was the context maybe the
Dalai Lama has been losing the Chris uh
the religious games of soccer and that
kid scored the the game-winning points
and it's totally acceptable I'm
celebrating if you bring it back to
sports it's more understandable what's
going on patreon now no who said all
right
it's been a great video I stand by it
.